by the way an update on benji he's lost
a ton of weight i don't know if you can
tell how much looking at him i said is
that really benji how much he lost i
think from the highest i've ever been on
the show i've lost uh like a hundred
pounds around 100 wow congratulations
awesome thank you thank you and now
benji um is seeing a male therapist i
don't know if it's i it just doesn't
feel as good i mean he's he's definitely
qualified and it just doesn't feel but
you want a girlfriend that's the problem
with the interaction with a woman i do
enjoy when a female therapist is sweet
and i don't feel any of that from him i
heard this benji yeah and this describes
you perfectly i think this male
therapist is good he said
benji
talks in circles
yes and that's a perfect example
whenever i've talked socially to benji
or asked him a question i get frustrated
because he talks in circles
that's what
let's say that's true but what do i do
with that you know how do i get better
it's like the verbal hokey pokey i'm
going to ask you a question i want to
see if you can just answer it how'd you
lose the weight i count i i mostly it's
by reducing calories i count the
calories and keep track of them and most
my
me being overweight is simply because i
i stuff too often
that that that was like my go-to drug
was stuffing stuffing stuffing myself
okay how'd you lose the weight
by reducing the calories so what i do
i mean reducing calories is what made me
lose the weight and and the way i did
that was uh
i i've gotten better at
uh
i uh keep track of the food i eat in
other words benji benji you see this is
it in other words there's a lot of ways
to reduce calories how did you reduce
calories i uh
i i said a cal caloric i i think i'm
actually answering
budget for myself it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter i get frustrated like
your therapist they do but really come
on that i was in other words some people
would say oh i went on weight watchers
or you know what i did i um every time i
ate i consulted a chart that tells me
the amount of calories or you know you
know what i mean it's hard to get an
answer no no howard you're not
you're not being sincere now i am being
so sincere it just goes
on and i look up in the sky and i
counted i counted calories and i had a
caloric butter
in other words
okay okay you counted calories got it
got it no he he then added after several
prompts that he had a budget he gave
himself a calorie
budget and then he started sticking to
that and that helped him lose anyone
listening to this how many calories a
day how many calories a day did you eat
to reduce down to 100 pounds that's
that's changed over time at at this
point it's a at between 1500 and 1550 a
day
um but not counting like pure greens
like like kale or
uh okay all right good good can i can i
just ask them a really quick question
because yeah yeah i read about all this
and this is this is such a simple answer
that i probably should have given uh two
minutes ago i understand that the way
you reduce calories was by weighing your
food is that true
um some foods i yes
that's your answer that's how you know
sometimes
but gary the reason i weigh is to get
the caloric total
so here's a little bit howard said how
did you how did you reduce your calories
you would say but you could waste you
could keep re you could keep like
reducing that answer how did i weigh the
food i had a scale a food scale how did
i get a food scale i ordered one on
amazon see what happens
do you see this it's happening again no
but but but saying i counted
and had a caloric budget is a is a very
precise answer well but you know say
that in the first sentence she said i
counted calories
i i i think one of the how many
headphones do you have on right now i'm
in a plane right now actually
why you got sunglasses on your head all
right nevermind i don't care
there's so many circles like i'm dizzy